i declare before you all
that my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
for decades queen elizabeth ii the
longest lived and longest reigning
monarch in britain's history was a
stabilizing force during a time of
change in the united kingdom
[Music]
her reign spanned the loss of most of
the country's colonies in the years
after world war ii
and more recently brexit and the
coronavirus pandemic
elizabeth alexandra mary windsor was
born in april 1926 the first child of
the duke and duchess of york
while cherished by the royal family
elizabeth was never expected to become
queen
her grandfather was king her uncle was
next in line but in 1936 her grandfather
died and her uncle abdicated
so we agreed england's new king george
six her father became king in
1937 making her
first in line to the throne
elizabeth's induction to royal duties
began during world war ii
when the 14 year old made her first
public broadcast
i can truthfully say to you all
that we children at home are full of
cheerfulness and courage
we are trying to do all we can
to help our gallant sailors soldiers and
airmen
in 1947
elizabeth married philip mountbatten
prince of greece and denmark and a
lieutenant in the royal navy on the
balcony at buckingham where many kings
and queens have appeared princess
elizabeth happily shares the supreme day
of her life with her countrymen
the couple's first son charles was born
in 1948
followed by anne andrew and edward
while she was on an official visit to
kenya elizabeth's life would change
forever
on february the 6th 1952 her father king
george failed to recover from an
operation and died at just 56 years old
elizabeth was flown back to london and
immediately seated to the throne
the high and mighty princess
elizabeth alexandra mary is now by the
death of our late sovereign of happy
memory become queen elizabeth ii
the queen was just 25 years old when she
started her royal duties as head of the
monarchy
even as britain lost most of its
colonies she remained head of state of
14 countries other than the uk
she traveled extensively and was
received with admiration by millions
mr president south africa has a special
place in my heart
and in the hearts of the british people
famously fond of horses the queen's love
of her corgis was also no secret
they appeared with her in a much loved
video shown during the opening ceremony
of london's 2012 olympic games
[Applause]
she rarely permitted interviews so not
much was known of her private life
but this seclusion from the press
changed in the 1990s
the queen described 1992 as anna's
horribles latin for horrible year
after windsor castle one of the queen's
royal residences caught fire and three
of her children announced they were
divorcing or separating from their
spouses
this included the very public separation
of her eldest son prince charles from
princess diana
people started to question if the royal
family was needed and if they reflected
modern britain
the queen came under criticism in 1997
when she didn't return quickly enough to
london to share in the public outpouring
of grief after princess diana died in a
car crash in paris
i want to pay tribute to diana myself
she was an exceptional and gifted human
being
in good times and bad
she never lost her capacity to smile and
laugh
nor to inspire others with her warmth
and kindness
after this speech public opinion started
to turn in favor of the royal family
following a well-crafted public
relations plan and the marriages between
kate middleton and prince william in
2011 and prince harry and meghan markle
in 2018
but just two years after their marriage
harry and megan announced they were
stepping away from royal duties in
search of privacy from a growing media
spotlight
they came to an agreement with the queen
where they would forfeit their royal
titles as well as any royal funding
their departure marked a watershed
moment for a royal family that had long
considered public service its foremost
duty
in her final years the queen addressed
her country and commonwealth as it was
swept up in the coronavirus pandemic
while we have faced challenges before
this one is different
this time we join with all nations
across the globe in a common endeavor
using the great advances of science
and our instinctive compassion to heal
[Music]
we are interrupting our normal
programmes to bring you an important
announcement
you're watching bbc news from london
a short while ago buckingham palace
announced the death of his royal
highness prince philip the duke of
edinburgh
in april 2021 prince philip the queen's
husband of over 70 years died at the age
of 99.
due to coronavirus restrictions his
funeral was a small family affair
attended by only 30 people
there were concerns for the queen's
health throughout 2022 she tested
positive for covid19 in february and in
june was forced to miss some platinum
jubilee events to mark her 70 years on
the throne due to mobility issues the
palace said
one of the queen's final acts was to
appoint conservative liz truss as prime
minister the 15th person to hold that
position during her reign
the queen will be laid to rest alongside
philip at the king george v memorial
chapel in windsor
her death means the crown now passes to
charles with william next in line to the
throne
in her 2018 christmas broadcast the
queen reflected on what had united her
kingdom the commonwealth of 2.4 billion
people and over 50 countries its
strength lies in the bonds of affection
it promotes
and a common desire to live in a better
more peaceful world
even with the most deeply held
differences
treating the other person with respect
and as a fellow human being is always a
good first step towards greater
understanding
you